this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality and host of the fine print
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
the fine print is the podcast with
ramsey networks that gets behind the
fine print you know the part where you
got screwed you remember and george has
been looking into that and making sure
we know where all of those are season
one has ten
episodes has the tenth one dropped today
today final episode final episode maybe
final forever but maybe just the final
of season one that's right so what is
the uh what what's the subject today
here's how to get to it this morning
what robin hood doesn't want you to know
about their investing app
this is a controversial one
but we've seen so many people they're
asking questions going hey should i be
investing in these apps doing micro
investing robo investing diy investing
and so we looked into it we talked to
some experts they've gotten a wee bit of
trouble on gamestop they've been in a
lot of trouble lately they had a giant
data breach that we didn't even insert
into the podcast there was so much to
cover we couldn't even cover the data
breach side but they uh had the biggest
fine from finra ever yeah that was on
the gamestop stuff right
yes and uh
you heard about the story of alex kearns
the college student who committed
suicide 20 years old thought he had a
negative 730 000 balance in his robin
hood app couldn't get in touch with
anyone at customer service
and so he took his own life because of
that incident he even said it in the
suicide note how could a 20 year old
leverage this much debt without knowing
what he's doing such a sad story
and so they've been under fire for a lot
of that they've been trying to do pr to
clean this up but you know this this
isn't a piece to bash diy investing or
bash robin hood but we want to let
people know too late what's going on
here yeah maybe a little late but listen
to the episode we talked to jerry walsh
over at finra so we actually interviewed
uh jerry who's over the investor
education
to really figure out what should people
know before they jump into these
investing apps and start doing
everything themselves because the
democratization of investing is great it
used to be you know only rich people on
wall street could jump into the stock
market but now anyone and their mom and
an 18 year old with a phone can make
some real risky decisions and get into
options trading single stocks
cryptocurrency all kinds of things
[Music]
nothing sounds good here
robin hood doesn't see it sound like
it's stole from the rich and gave to the
poor to me not quite not quite and you
know what the game i'm not thinking and
made marion's happy here
i'm just this is just my thought okay
well check out the podcast it's called
the fine print and everything is uh is
there you know so be sure you you know
be sure you step into that and don't
don't miss out on any of it open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five sherry is with us to start off
this hour in tucson arizona hi sherry
how are you
good how are you today better than i
deserve what's up in your world
okay i've been listening to you
and
what's happening is i started out in my
life uh having the role models of spend
you know splurge spend even if you can't
afford it so i never learned how to do
finances correctly however i am now 72
divorced nine years have my own home
get free but i right now what i'm
looking at listening to your advice
is
some of the monies i have are they
better
off
going to pay off my mortgage rather than
you know sitting in the bank and making
no money yeah
how much do you owe on your house
uh i replied so now it's 89 000.
okay
and how much money do you have in the
bank
i have um let me see
uh
over 50 000 some i will use to you know
fix up my home a little or vacation or
emergency but
you know it's a chunk
fifty thousand and how much do you have
in your nest egg you have retirement
savings as well
um i have retirement i have and i have a
guaranteed income right so i'm not
hurting in that respect how much is in
your retirement and how much is your
guaranteed income
okay my garrett okay my in my retirement
yes my own retirement is only about 50
60 000 okay the you know retirement fund
okay
so you got 100 000 bucks to your name
give or take
and you owe 89 000 on your house and
your guaranteed retirement income is how
much
okay and every month uh between
everything i rece let me let me think
this who i should know it by now about
four thousand
okay very good very good yeah what
you've done better than
you've done very well yeah
so here's the thing recently
obviously
a paid for house
would make your golden years
relaxed
yes so that should be our goal
but we don't have to panic about it
um you need an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
and how much is this mortgage payment
every month
um the mortgage is wait let me enough to
think i'm a little nervous um not real
it's not real high it's um
with taxes and everything yeah
750 a month okay so with that 750 a
month that's going to be added to that
income and really help you live out this
retirement so i do want this house paid
for um and like dave saying once you
have that emergency fund in place out of
that 50 000 then i would put whatever
else is remaining on there and put that
on the loan yeah let's just make it kind
of round numbers for a second
let's set aside 25 000. how much did you
said you had some repairs to do did i
hear that
um well it's r it's repair and
improvement i'm i'm estimating it'll be
20 but that may not happen for another
year or so
and i plan to use cash not charge
anything you better you better okay yeah
all right so okay we need to set aside
25 000 for your emergency fund um and
let's set aside 15 000 for repairs and
renovation okay
in a separate account
two different little accounts and then
let's put the other 10 000 on the house
that gets it down to about
79 and then let's just begin to pay
extra on the house as you can out of
your monthly budget and let's get that
house paid off as quickly as you can so
that then you could have smooth sailing
in there so you should be done in yeah
probably done in five years
probably seventy seconds that's what i'd
like to do that's what i'd like to do
because i'm sorry that's what i would do
yeah do it
do you have the margin
oh i'm i'm in good shape i bought my car
for cash before you put an extra
thousand dollars a month on this house
pretty easy can't you
i probably could yeah
yeah and that put that put you down in
five years with the 30 with putting 15
or 20 000 out of your current account on
there setting aside 15 for repair
setting aside 25 for
uh
your emergency fund and there's nothing
wrong with this formula the beautiful
thing is if you if you're 87
and your house is paid for if you're 77
and your house is paid for if you're 27
and your house is paid for it puts you
in a completely different headspace
your emotions your spirit
and the arithmetic all changes and it's
called financial peace
two words that don't go together like
fouchy math
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
well the christmas countdown is on and
me with the rest of the team at ramsey
solutions we're in a christmas frame of
mind already we love christmas around
here it's become a christmas tradition
to give away a boatload of cash every
year we celebrate christmas with our
ramsay show listeners with our ramsey
christmas cash
giveaway
big tradition this year we're giving
away five hundred dollars a week we've
already started and a grand prize of
five thousand dollars
uh you can enter every day to increase
your chances of winning go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway and if
you're looking for life-changing gifts
for your family and friends our famous
week-long black friday sale is here this
week only get 73 off best sellers makes
perfect gifts uh books are great
stocking stuffers and we got gifts for
him gifts for her gifts for kids
check it all out the life-changing book
that sold so many copies the total money
makeover is only 20
the new book baby steps millionaire that
comes out in january is on pre-sale just
launched the pre-sale on it first book
i've done in eight years it's on there
as well all kinds of stuff check it all
out black friday sale everything online
at
ramseysolutions.com ramseysolutions.com
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five solomon is with us solomon
is in new york city if i were to push
the right button i would be talking to
solomon there we go hey solomon what's
up
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve man how can we help
so i
i've two questions one of them kind of
runs into the other well basically
um
i i saw you started seeing your videos
on youtube and uh
i am i'm 18 years old and i'm already i
read the total money makeover and i have
a thousand dollars saved
um
so i'm just wondering what
what should my baby steps look like
i'm starting with no debt and no
experience
[Laughter]
well you got a good early start my
brother i'm glad you called
so let's be here solomon you're 18 and
you have no debt and you're wondering
what the next step is after this baby
step one that you're at
that's right okay well the next step for
you would be baby step three because
you're out of consumer debt so we want
you to fully fund that emergency fund
that you've started and so whatever
three to six months of expenses looks
like for you i want you to save that up
as quickly as possible um before we ever
get to any kind of investing
yeah are you okay are you living at home
still
yeah cool okay and what are you doing
for a living
i'm actually still in school but um um
i'm not i'm not going to debt for it
awesome
okay what are you studying um
i'm still in rabbinical
wonderful okay good for you good for you
well here's what i would do if i were in
your shoes i would just pile up as much
cash as i can pile up until graduation
when will you graduate
uh the end of this year god willing oh
wow wonderful okay
and then you will move into uh
what is your next step in your career
then
um i'm actually not sure
it's not it's not a clearly defined
system i might move home and get a job
and uh and then i can start really
piling up stuff
but i'm not exactly sure
okay all right so you don't um
when you graduate from rabbinical school
you don't automatically move into a paid
rabbi position then i don't know how
this works so i'm asking because i mean
no
that's right okay so you would go get a
a job in the mainstream and then uh move
into your rabbinical studies and and uh
ministry later on is that right
right okay all right cool so what are
you going to do for a living after you
graduate do you think
oh um i i mean i have i have a couple
friends who own these like companies in
different
different industries and i'm just like i
guess i'm going to try around trying to
get some uh
experience that's good okay great well
what i would do is this
this next um
24 to 36 months is going to be highly
transitional you're going to be moving
you're going to be taking on new jobs
you might be setting up your first
apartment with a furniture and hookup
and hooking up cable or whatever
uh the internet whatever you're going to
do you know however you're going to live
and you because all of that transition
because you're still
very young in the process it's fine to
just have a huge pile of cash like for
instance if you had 50 000 cash saved i
wouldn't be mad at you i don't want it
invested at this stage i want you to get
settled and steady in your income before
you start worrying about your
investments
and uh but right now just a big old pile
of cash it's like grease in the gears
man it'll just cause that cause stuff to
happen and if the the more money you
piled up the less desperate you are to
get a job
and so you don't take the wrong job with
the wrong people the toxic environment
or a thing you hate doing just because
it looks like it might make you money
and instead you can get into something
that's a true act of service that
follows in
uh in the rabbinical rabbinical mindset
and can move you out in that direction
so yeah just give yourself this pad
between
uh all of the garbage out there and life
called life and that pad is called money
so just a big old pile of cash and then
you know when you're 23
22 and you kind of got a rhythm to your
income then you start worrying about
investing and start thinking about
buying homes and those kinds of things
but right now let's just see how much
cash you can pile up yeah i remember
being 18 and solomon's got so much
wisdom for an eighteen-year-old to even
be asking the question here's the name
it's solomon wisdom i didn't put two and
two together look at that but i remember
being a sure
uh but at 18 i was living at home and i
was spending every paycheck i got and it
was gone and i wish i had the wisdom to
go hey what if i could save this so that
oh yeah as i step into adulthood i've
got a pile of money and set a pile of
debt and stress would you love to have a
rabbi named solomon that's amazing this
would be pretty cool right here this is
destiny all right aaron is with us
erin's in lexington hi erin how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i had to hear you say that until they
really asked hey i want to keep it brief
i know you want everybody to do the same
i have a tricky situation uh everyone
does me and my wife are going to get a
home in the next couple months
we've been living in my brother's
basement we've paid off every debt
except her student loan and her car
but the tricky thing is my mother is
gonna probably be moving in with us she
has a home now but she's gonna sell her
home live with us
the good part of that is she's gonna
probably purchase 25 of the home where
she's going to be living with us she's
going to sell hers the tricky part of
this situation
is that
by aunts her sister is in charge of her
estate has been since my grandfather
died my grandfather knew she was
terrible with money
and she is so he his will he put that
she he wanted my my aunt to be in charge
so that she didn't burn through her
estate
but the only problem is my aunt is never
ever once told my mom or me or my
brother how much she got she's never
told us anything this has been nine
years now she's being very difficult
with the fact that now we're going to
have my mother move in she's asking all
kinds of questions she's
like
to be honest she's coming across as this
she doesn't want her to kind of because
she's gonna have to tell us some answers
as to what's going on she's told my mom
she just last christmas she told my
mother that she was merely out of money
and was going to have to figure out what
we're going to do with her because she's
almost out and now we bring up the
proposition she's going to move with us
and now she all of a sudden what's your
household in 12 years
my household income is about seven
seventy five hundred a month okay you're
not going to like my answer much
well i probably not okay
you shouldn't do any of this
okay
number one you're broken in debt you
don't need to be buying a house
number two you don't let someone who you
have absolutely no idea what's going on
with their finances and you've got all
this conflict going on own 25 of the
house you're gonna own with your wife
this is a recipe for marital discord
okay you ain't seen pissed off till you
seem pissed off like your wife's gonna
be when this story ends
right bad idea dude you're putting a lot
of hot sauce in the chili man
you is asking for it okay well what what
about
is there anything we can do i think your
mom needs to stand on her own somewhere
and be taken care of by your aunt until
your aunt decides that she wants to come
clean with the finances you don't need
to buy a house anyway for your mom
and you don't need to buy a house with
your mom even after you're in good shape
financially if you want to let her live
with you as a tenant that's fine but you
need to buy your own house after you're
out of debt and not before if your aunt
won't come clean with what's going on
you can hire an attorney drag her before
the judge and have the judge do a full
audit on the finances and expose them to
the family and maybe remove her as power
of attorney sounds like that is what
needs to happen by the way because
barney fife your aunt is out of control
but that's a side issue that's not when
she owns 25 of your house
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage morgan is with us
hey morgan how are you i'm great dave
how are you better than i deserve
welcome where do you live i live in
outside of greensboro north carolina oh
okay nice trip over the mountains this
time of year to come see us sure was
good to have you and uh how much debt
have you paid off i paid off sixty two
thousand seven hundred and ten dollars
way to go and your range of income
during that time started at about fifty
five thousand and this year will be
about seventy eight thousand cool and i
skipped over how long did that take 23
months twenty three way to go
good job good job all right so what kind
of debt was this 63 000 oh man okay so
it was a little bit of everything had
some furniture a tv
a personal convenience loan i had four
credit cards a car loan and a truck loan
a personal convenience
of course
was it convenient
it was convenient until she got it then
it wasn't convenient exactly that's how
it works that's a nice brand i like that
brand yeah it's making this makes it
sound so innocuous so you were kind of
normal you borrowed everything i did how
old are you
32. okay and so you started this journey
when you were 30. yes and you looked up
and said
yeah all right so how did you get
connected to ramsey and tell us your
story sure well i'll have to go a few
months before i started i got my dream
job at a company i had tried to been uh
to get on to for a long time several
years and with that came a pay increase
and so i thought that was the key
that's right that fixes everything um
but i wasn't budgeting correctly and i
was spreading all of my extra income
across all my debts so i wasn't making
any progress
and so my dad had mentioned dave ramsey
and i should check him out but i didn't
of course and um then one day i was on
linkedin and i saw a post about how a
guy paid off all his student loans using
the um debt snowball and the baby steps
and i was like
there's that dave ramsey name again
there he is and so um i researched it
and dug in and i bought the total money
makeover
and that was actually the last thing i
bought on my amazon credit card
so isn't that lovely
so
oh a curse on the book
you've got five percent off right
shut up there we go
that makes it okay
um and so i read the book and um i'm not
much of a reader but i read it pretty
fast uh i think in a week's time because
it's easy to read and i just uh
attacked it littlest biggest i laid
everything out and i didn't realize how
much i had actually
ranked up um i knew i had some debt and
i knew i needed to fix it but i didn't
have the drive to fix it until then wow
did it feel overwhelming when you listed
it out for the first time and really
added it up yeah it was like how am i
ever going to
get this done
so what was that journey like when you
when you paid off that first little debt
what'd you feel oh my gosh it was very
gratifying and like well maybe i can
actually do this
you know because i and i was spreading
my extra income across my different
debts before i read the total money
makeover and i wasn't making any
progress so that i mean that's hard when
you're not making any progress and um
and feeling like like you're not getting
anywhere and i made this
income i thought was big at the time and
so um you know that should fix my
problems but it didn't so what
sacrifices were you making you were
throwing half your income at this debt
yeah well um
the the pandemic helped because we um
everything was at home um so we did a
lot of cooking and eating at home my son
and i
and um
we actually turned down a trip to disney
world this year a free stay at disney
world so we made some there's no such
thing
exactly and i knew that because
exactly
you walked through the gate they got you
they do was that a time share
presentation by any chance well
i think my aunt uncle have a time share
so uh oh yeah so that was how we were
going to stay but anyway wow yeah very
impressive well done i'm proud of you
thank you me too so i'm guessing your
dad was cheering you along he was who
were your other cheerleaders well my
family for sure and my son okay and some
of them came with you to cheer you on
today
who came with you so that's my boyfriend
micah my son zeke my mom lisa and then
my sister-in-law and her son oh wow
lucas it's a good nashville trip that's
right we've had some fun so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you did it in 23 months when you
start it's overwhelming you got your
stomach in your throat you can't you
can't breathe and then they pay off the
little minimum well maybe i can do this
and then the next one maybe i can yeah
this is going to work yeah this is going
to work exactly so what's the key to
getting out of debt the key is really
just to stick to the plan don't try to
cut any corners or
make it work with your situation like
there's just follow the plan it's simple
it's hard but it's simple
so i think that's the key is just
sticking to it you know some of the most
profound life-changing things in the
world are easy to understand and hard to
do absolutely love your neighbor yep
yeah but he's a jerk exactly how's that
possible get the idea but
exactly which neighbor can i pick yes
yeah
modify the plan
yeah everybody wants to ish
but uh profound life-changing things
principles that we live our lives by
values are uh simple to understand and
hard to execute because they require
dealing with a person in our mirror
that's right so i'm proud of you thank
you really well done i know your
family's proud of you and your voice
proud of you he got to watch you do this
he sure did and it changes uh changes
the way he views things he'll remember
my mom the single mom she for 23 months
she we busted it and she changed our
lives that's right you're a hero and run
running in the car he would say dave
ramsey again because we listen to the
podcast me too that's what my wife says
way to go i'm so proud of you thank you
good stuff we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story as you're on your way to
being a baby steps millionaire
and a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away start someone's journey
the way yours got started that same
exact book that's right so very cool
very very very well done all right you
want to get zeke up in the in the debt
free screen picture here let's do that
he's excited zeke again he's seven seven
yeah a good-looking young man yes he is
all right zeke and morgan from
greensboro north carolina 63 000 dollars
paid off 23 months making 55-78
count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two
one
[Applause]
that's awesome
he gets to use his outdoor voice inside
that's why he's so excited that's fun
good for zeke he likes dave ramsey now
very well done well for the next few
minutes and then after that but yeah
oh that's awesome you know what's
interesting is um
all these years of doing this
there's every demographic
um
race creed color marital status
income
background region
has stood on that stage and done their
debt free screen
there's nothing there's no correlation
to any of like how you were brought up
whether you're married with your single
mom
whether you're make a hundred thousand
dollars a year when you make forty
thousand dollars a year whether you make
fifty five to seventy eight thousand
dollars a year the only correlation that
i've ever been able to see across all of
the data that's walked across those
stages in front of me over 30 years is
that they decided they could
that's a good observation
i mean here's a single mom
i mean you know tough single moms got it
i mean that's tough
they got a lot they got to do everything
by themselves
and she's got a good family support
system around her and other things and
obviously she's a very whole person
talking to her i mean she's very
well-rounded very bright very wise but
uh it's a tough gig
and and yet she paid off 63 000 in three
months and i got people completely
healthy marriages making a hundred and
twenty thousand and even amg's not
realistic well kiss my butt let me just
tell you about dave ramsey being
realistic let me just tell you her name
is morgan and she just did it and made
you look bad
she just completely shamed you no
excuses yeah and she could have had him
because she i mean she's doing a lot
there's so many reasons she could have
gone well the debt can wait everybody's
got a dead blame excuse not to win until
they go win
everybody's got a dead gun excuse until
your butt gets on fire and you say
that's it i'm done i'm not living like
this anymore i've had it and that's the
demographic that changes their life
is you just light yourself on fire and
see who wants to come see the fire you
know i mean let's get it let's get it
put on a show and then people say well
then they've got they criticized the
fire meanwhile you're changing your
whole life and zeke's family tree
mic drop baby well done there it is this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk to you about
your life and your money it's common
sense for your dollars and cents jeremy
is in evansville indiana hi jeremy how
are you
i'm good to you better than i deserve
man what's up
uh just got a quick question i want to
get your input uh on whether i should
take advantage of this uh crazy auto
market right now and sell my current
vehicle i have a truck that i bought
brand new um
before i really took upon your uh your
ways and it's gone up actually in this
value or in this market right now as far
as value that's when i have the
opportunity it is and uh i have the
opportunity to sell it um like later
today and i'm just kind of wanting to
see if you think that's a good idea uh
like i said my perspective has changed
on this a lot as far as vehicles go and
uh and losing value
so i have no debt right now we have no
debt uh really there's no emergency this
would basically just kind of shoot us
into baby step four and some
so what will the trucks sell for today
um they're
about 38 000. now watch your household
income
uh right around
150 to 170 it varies depending on
overtime and things like that
what's the truck what kind of truck is
it
uh one of your favorites it's a 2018
tacoma it's a great truck yeah
okay i love it i absolutely love it like
i said it's the only reason why i would
tell at this point is just what's the
other car we're actually making money
uh
as far as my wife's car
i'm wanting to say i think we
just looked into it recently it's right
on 27 000. it's a 2018 toyota camry okay
well here's the thing
the you've heard us talk about this
obviously and it's made you think about
this and you can do whatever you want to
do
there's no uh
there's no uh uh you're stupid in this
discussion okay no column we check that
box
so you can keep it or you can sell it um
and here's why
the car a car is the largest thing all
of us buy just about all of us buy
that goes down in value
and so it's a big item and it goes the
wrong way
so they all suck
financially
okay there's not a good one
there's not a good one and we've got an
anomaly in the market right now where it
actually went up in value but that's the
first time in a 100 years that cars have
gone up in value and it won't last okay
it's just till the supply chain gets
straightened out the supply demand curve
evens uh and then it'll it you know
they'll start going down again like a
rock that's where chevy gets that like a
rock so um
this is the the it's just a fact okay so
given that years ago when we first
started teaching people to become baby
steps millionaires we determined that
there are two measures if somebody has
too much car one is if they can't pay
off all their debt not counting their
house in two years well you've already
you're debt free so that doesn't even
apply to you and the second one george
the second one as far as okay if you buy
a car new no you don't you don't want to
buy a car new unless you're uh what
you've already got this car but if
you're going to call me am i going to
buy a new car i want you to have a
million dollar net worth i didn't ask
you about that oh but if if you don't
want more because they're so big and
they go down in value you don't want
more than half of your annual income
even if everything's paid for
tied up in things going the wrong way
anything with a motor in it yeah
anything with a motor or wheels
totaled up it doesn't need to be more
than half your annual income because you
know let's say in your case you make 175
000 a year so if you had a hundred and
ten thousand dollars worth of vehicles
going the wrong way that's going to
weigh you down in your wealth building
right you don't absolutely you don't
you've got about 50 something thousand
and you make 175 000 a year so yours is
not out of line
it's a little high and it's kind of
stinging you because you got new
information the way you're processing
this emotionally but there's no
financial thing screaming that you need
to sell this truck and you like the
truck
i'm personally going to keep it if it's
me are you just trying to fast track
baby step three right now
uh you know i mean we're pretty much
good on baby step three so it kind of
like just launches fully into baby step
four um and the other part of this to
kind of throw in the equation is i'm i'm
a police officer so i actually have a
take-home car and that's what i drive 95
of the time so this truck just sits in
the garage and i'm you know normally i
just feel like i'm sitting there
watching it go down in value while i
never use it and so if i did this it'd
be basically to kind of let the market
calm back down and then find a better
deal on a used car that i'd still be
pretty happy with well you can do that
that's not an unwise thing it's not an
unwise thing and so yeah this is a this
is get out while the getting's good kind
of thing i'm with you exactly and so i i
i think that's you know you're topping
out the market because you know two
months from now it's probably not going
to be that way
this is probably this is probably your
one shot at pulling this deal off
and like you said you can go buy
something for half this price
when the market evens back out that is a
really nice truck still
absolutely especially for a driveway
sitter
exactly
you know so yeah i'm with you i think
it's okay but i just want you to
understand it's not the same weight
as if you had a hundred and ten thousand
dollars worth of vehicles
because guys call me up making 250 and
they want to buy a 200 000 lamborghini
and i kick their little butts
because that's just stupid short-term
thinking that's friday night i'm going
to spend all my money that's all that is
as a child
and you're not doing that you're doing
the opposite of that so i wanted to talk
through the critical thinking
of this but i agree with you i think i'd
do what you're doing if i woke up in
your shoes there's no problem with
keeping it though you're not on the
bubble you're not out of line
if you just rethink this and go you know
i just really like this thing i'm gonna
keep it well that's okay
you know but if you wanted to get out
and come up with something six months
from now that was half the price and
still a really nice vehicle this is the
month to do it
because i don't i mean it could last two
more months but i don't think it's gonna
last six more months i'm positive
as positive as i can be about anything
it's not gonna last six more months but
you know george what's that that there's
only two people that can keep their jobs
and be wrong all the time weather
forecasters and economists
that's good i should have chose a
different career path
that's good well and apparently uh
mathematicians in the medical profession
too that's another one but yeah you can
keep their jobs and be wrong all the
time but other than that the rest of us
have to be right most of the time so i
i'm actually guessing but i'm looking at
supply demand curves i'm looking at
what's settling out i'm watching these
supply chains smooth out and i'm
watching some of the tsunami following
the pandemic so we shut down the whole
freaking economy that was an earthquake
following an earthquake at sea there's
always a tsunami and then we have this
tsunami hit which is all this labor
disruption the supply chain disruption
the supply demand disruption and so
there's a shortage on everything which
immediately drives the price
artificially up and so all this
hyperinflation you're seeing
you know you can blame joe biden if you
want to but you'd be wrong
i'm not a joe biden fan but he didn't
cause this
pandemic shutdown caused this
and everybody freaking out shutting down
the whole freaking world
uh caused this and
the economic disruption that we chose
when we chose to quarantine the entire
world that's what caused this
and so if you want to blame something
that's what you blame now there is one
thing you can blame joe biden for on the
prices no doubt about it and that's gas
prices because he keeps tinkering with
all the energy policy and he's screwing
with it and he put opec back in charge
and that's going to drive prices to
double so you got double at your gas
pump that is his fault
but the other economic stuff is not you
can try to blame it on him if you want
it may it may affect fall elections but
it's not his fault it's the tsunami
following this stuff and that's what
we're all experiencing right now and so
lumber prices are through the roof or
whatever whatever you housing prices and
there's a shortage and everybody's
running around buying up everything and
christmas is going to be horrible
because we're not going to be able to
get our little jungle gym thing or
whatever there's a lot of just fear and
people are freaking out about inflation
and i think the best thing you can do
is to do the baby steps get out of that
i was 22 years old in 1982
when carter went out
and
i walked through my teenage years with
gas prices and gas lines
and shortages
and real inflation that went on for a
decade that was double digits wow 10 a
year steady that's inflation to be
afraid of
inflation that spiked temporarily
brought on by this by the supply demand
curve screw up and out there is not
something i'm panicking about but if i
thought these guys were doing monetary
policy that was you know driving
inflation now obviously they're spending
money like they're in congress up there
and and so that's going to do that's
going to hurt it too that's going to
slow the recovery from this down the
recovery of this because you sprint
money like that but that's also not
what's causing it because that money's
not been injected in the economy yet
so it's just the perception of that
that's blowing everybody's mind and then
the poli you politicize it and want to
argue about it then you go bananas makes
for a better headline well and you lose
all your critical thinking skills when
you start talking politics so just melt
down
all in the name of what you supposedly
believe
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsay show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're here to answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the last episode of season one for the
fine print our uh
expose on all things that screw you
through fine print uh is out with george
campbell and uh it's absolutely
incredible the last episode drops today
so be sure and check that out it's a
ramsey network's production and george
and his team have done a fabulous job
putting these together
colin is with us in charlottesville
virginia to start this hour hey colin
how are you
oh i'm doing well sir how are you better
than i deserve what's up
awesome well so um
i've been lucky enough for the past 11
years to have been married to a
financial peace baby
um but in my stubbornness i've been
unlucky enough to not listen to her
um thankfully we are out of debt we're
actually in baby step four um and part
way into five
um but i was curious to know um my
employer just this year started offering
roth 401k
as one of our benefits
along with the traditional and
they match five percent of my pay
in the traditional and then sometime
next year they're supposed to give us an
option to either maintain
our cash balance pension
or turn that off
and then they'll give us
two percent into the roth as long as we
match it
and currently i'm putting in 10 and 10
into the roth
and the 5 that they match into the
traditional i just want to know your
thoughts on that
the only way you can take a match is
traditional
you don't have a choice in that
the uh absolutely so the match is a five
percent traditional that's what the law
says and then the new two percent when
you turn off the pension next year will
be traditional as well now you can roll
it to a roth each year so i i take my
match i match myself i own the company
it's kind of stupid but
i match myself and then i i roll my
match after the first of the year every
year into the roth and pay the taxes on
it
so it will keep going but my house is
paid for you're in baby step four or
five six you wouldn't do that you would
just take the match and take the roth
yeah are you so you're not investing a
full 15 right now
no i am i have 10 going into the roth
right now and then i'm putting in five
into the traditional which they're also
matching
yeah you don't need to be
don't match in the roth yeah you don't
need to be doing the five percent you
can do that in the roth and they'll
match the five percent but it'll go to
the traditional side
there
so the way it really the way it reads
and when i spoke to hr my hr department
they said it will not they're not going
to match our five percent unless we put
it into traditional
that doesn't make sense
they called me on the phone and i asked
very very clearly and they also followed
me up with an email in print
that said the same thing
um i would go into your 401k and check
the actual balances and see what's
adding up there but because i do 15 here
at ramsey into our roth 401k and they
still match and it goes to traditional
the match has to be in traditional but
the amount you get matched on
does not have to be in a traditional by
law now they could have that
as a
regulation or rule within their own 401k
at your company but i will tell you in
all my years of doing this that's the
first time i've ever heard of that
that's why i think you've misunderstood
that's very well and that's what i was i
don't see and that's i thought it was
weird too it's there's no benefit to
them at all
yet pretty much none um and and that's
what's what's crazy is that when i i
double checked on the two percent that
they said they were going to match to
the roth
as long as we turned off the cash
balance pension and they they double
verified that that was correct as well
um because i thought the same thing you
can only match into traditional so yeah
no i don't know the match
that they give you
that money has to be traditional the
money you're putting in that they are
matching
again can be roth by law
now whether or not they are allowing
that i'm not sure they can even do what
you're describing by law
so i really do think that this is
confused i think you guys either your hr
person has got it wrong or you've
misunderstood what they're saying the
five percent that they give you the two
percent that they give you as a match
has to be in the traditional
it can be matching however what is in
the roth and i i'm i don't even think
they've got the right to do it otherwise
i i
i think once i say i match something as
the employer i have to match either roth
or traditional
whatever you put in now the portion that
i match with again
goes into traditional so to be very
clear but anyway check on that and
that's what you should do you should be
putting 15 of your income away as much
of it in roth as you can that you get
the match always get all the match and
yes if they give you two percent extra
for dropping the other thing i'm
probably dropping the other thing
you can run some math on what it's worth
we don't know what it's worth in this
discussion today but most of the time
where you can control your money instead
of it being in a pension you're going to
make more and it doesn't die when you
die
pensions die with you and um this money
as it piles up is your money at death
and it leaves it's left to your family
your beneficiary on your 401k dave we
get this question a lot of if my
employer matches do i still do the 15
where do where do you stand as far as
you know i mean answer it tell them what
to do so as far as i know if you've got
a mandatory contribution from your own
paycheck you say you can count that at
about half
if it's mandatory it's mandatory from
your own paycheck and but any and if you
don't control what it's going into
that's different but in a 401k you
control it you control what it's going
into but this is something like a state
pension plan or estate plan of some kind
most of the time that's where it is
sometimes it's a large union thing or
something like that there is a railroad
there's some of that where you have a
mandatory seven percent that they're
taking out of your check and you don't
even control what it goes into
in that case i wouldn't count all of it
but the matching portion doesn't count
as a 15
that's just icing that's just extra
money oh darn i hate it when i have more
money at retirement i hate it when that
happens
so 15 of your income out of your pocket
should go at baby step four into
retirement planning that's household
income now you and your wife you and
your husband add your money together 15
of that figure should be going first to
get all the matches you can get
second to all the roth you can get and
third and lastly only then do you do
traditional if you have to and if you
don't have a roth 401k option you say
let's go over to the roth ira exactly if
you're eligible for that get all the
wrongs you can get get all the roth you
can get because that's tax free but 100
return on your money with a match
even if you've got to pay taxes on it
and that's out more than tax free nets
out
so you take the match always first and
then roth from there all you can do and
that's you know so it's rock paper
scissors
match beats roth beats traditional
that's all you got to remember right
down the line
and that'll work
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
when it comes to building wealth most
people have been sold the lie that they
need a massive income or a huge
inheritance to even have a shot at
becoming a millionaire that's not true
over the past 30 years countless people
have built incredible wealth by
following the baby steps
and we call those folks baby steps
millionaires
and here's what i really want you to
hear
you
can do exactly what they did
and everything you need to make it
happen is in the best year ever bundle
it's just what you need to start
building the right habits this year for
your journey to millionaire status you
get a copy of the brand new book baby
steps millionaires comes out of course
january the 11th gives you the clear
practical steps that lead to a million
dollar net worth
you also get financial peace university
and every dollar as a part of a ramsey
plus membership the premium version of
every dollar so you're gonna have the
best budgeting tool the best financial
class and the brand new book to get you
there
when you use these tools and follow
these principles you will pay off all of
your debt build wealth and yes even
become a millionaire
get the best year ever bundle by
visiting ramseysolutions.com
best
this is the ramsey show thank you for
being with us george camel ramsey
personality is my co-host open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
randy is with us in alberta canada or
edmonton alberta i'm sorry it is alberta
canada how can we help randy
hey george and dave it's a pleasure to
talk to you guys you too what's up
so i'm uh discovered your program back
in january and i've paid off about 70
000 in debt already um i should be back
free months first
but i do have a rental i own with my
mother where 50 50 partners on it
and uh just curious whether i should be
adding that into my debt snowball or
so i maybe look at selling mom's good
either way
the partnership's
going really great
she's she supports me in my financial
journey so either way would work for her
i just wanted to hit your thoughts on
that
you own the home you live in
yes i own the home i live in and is it
paid off yeah
no no
sorry when i say debt free in my
marketplace
how much do you owe on your home
my home i owe 245.
and how much equity is in the rental
uh equity and rental is about 60 000.
so you get 30 each if you sold it
correct
how's the market there
um market was covered it actually went
down quite a bit it's slowly coming back
um
it's not where it should be yet but uh
it's getting better all the time economy
is picking up here so definitely not
red-hot though okay
well in general
uh i'm going to move you out of that but
over time i'm not in a hurry if it takes
you two years or three years and you
want to kind of ride this economy back
up because a lot of areas in north
america of course are quite hot real
estate you're quite the opposite
uh you're kind of cooled off it sounds
like and so um
uh you know i might ride that a little
bit there's nothing panicking here but
in general if you didn't own the rental
while you've got debt on your home i
wouldn't take money out of your pocket
to go buy a rental instead i would pay
it down on your home and so in this case
i would reverse the process
if that's what was going on uh but i'm
not in a hurry to do it i don't know you
got any thoughts on that yeah i mean you
have you have 70 how much debt do you
have left other than these two mortgages
uh 27 000 10 what's your what's your
household income
uh 110 i missed that okay i'll sell it
now
so you could clear your consumer debt if
you sold this it sounds like
immediately yeah that's what i would do
i missed that you had consumer debt
somehow i thought i heard you were
debt-free except your house i goofed you
said you're debt-free march first
march
correct yeah i mean i don't know how
much more the housing market will
increase if it's going to skyrocket but
i'd want to be debt-free sooner than
march 1st if you can just do it in one
fell swoop here and get out of the
situation with with mom and owning the
house
yeah
yeah
it's not i'm not upset about mom at this
stage of the game i'm not upset about
the rental but uh
i do want that personal debt cleared and
then let's just turn around and attack
the house yeah i think you did this out
of order and so i would undo it all
right now go ahead and sell it now
uh i mean i saw it
right this second but sometime around
the first a year let's put on the market
make a move on it get your debts all
cleaned up and move on yeah that's what
i would do i missed that good catch good
catch that's what i'm here for that's it
got my back got my back rick is in boise
hi rick how are you
i'm great how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up
well i
need some advice on my particular uh
financial situation
just to give you a little background i'm
60 i will be 65 this spring
and um
i am debt-free with the exception of my
home
and i have virtually nothing saved i've
been kind of a small business owner all
my life
and uh entrepreneur
so i've not been lucky enough to really
have had
extra money to save
however that has kind of changed here in
the last couple years i have a business
that is doing very well comparative to
my history
and so although i don't have anything
saved i have income
and i'm wondering
what you think i should do with the
income that i have coming in it's it's
way more than i
have a very simple life so i don't i
have a lot of inc disposable extra
income right now what should i do what
is this income
it's my self-employment income i don't
know how my company
oh how much um about 150 000 okay a year
what's it take you to live
[Music]
okay so you can bank a hundred
pretty darn close and you said your
house is paid for or not
no i own 200 000 on my hall okay
all right
well i i would be banking um a big chunk
of this i'd be banking 15 percent of
your household income that's 30 000 um
roughly let's go ahead and round it up
to 30. make it a little more make it 20
000 20 and then i'd throw the rest of it
at the house until the house is paid off
and the house is paid for a bank 100 a
year how long can you keep working at
this rate
my goal is i want to work until i'm 70.
i'm pretty healthy so i don't see any
issues with that you know
god willing but um i'd like to be done
by by the time i'm 70.
my plan is is is that
i'm hoping to be able to sell my company
when i'm 70.
and that will give me
probably close to a million dollars
before tax
maybe it's worth more who knows what
it's going to be worth five years from
now but
um you know that will certainly help i
have some rental income
um about forty eight thousand dollars a
year which actually i didn't add into
the to the 150s is the rental paid for
it is paid for okay and your but your
mortgage isn't on your primary
yes yeah i have a house payment of about
thirteen hundred dollars a month with a
two hundred and fifteen thousand dollar
balance
so the goal five years from today is how
much can you have in investments and
still end up with your house paid for
that's what i want say that again i want
you to put as much as you can in
investments and still have your house
paid for so i think you can pay for your
house in about three years while putting
30 000 away
that'd be a hundred thousand in there
and then the other two years you put 100
to 200 000 away so you should end up
with a half million dollar nest egg and
a paid for house and a paid for rental
and whatever the business brings
right at 70.
yeah that's that's kind of my plan that
was just
the only caveat here is if the business
doesn't sell for a million dollars what
do you do then because it's not worth a
million dollars today
it's not today no but
you know
covet has been um
pretty good to me if you if you want to
say it like that you know i this is a
company that's made about 40 to 50 000 a
year for the last 12 years
and um so what happens what what kind of
a business is it
well i own a biohazard removal company
so we do a lot of homicide suicide
cleanup kind of stuff wow
[Applause]
wow what a mess
no pun intended yeah i was gonna say
that's spot on
ouch
well okay i don't know if it'll be worth
a million then but i want you to have a
half million in savings in a paid for
house and a paid for rental when you get
to 70 and you budget to make that happen
that's my game plan if i'm in your shoes
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage richard and jennifer are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you
good where do you guys live colorado
harvard colorado all right welcome to
nashville and all the way over here to
do a debt free screen absolutely thank
you thank you for having us absolutely
how much have you paid off so it's a
good one george you gonna write this
down i'm writing
407 000.
seven and a half years
cool and your range of income during
that time 125 to about 200 000 now good
for you what do you guys do for a living
so i'm in pharmaceutical sales yeah i've
been doing that 20 years which is
why you
were a big impact in our life getting to
a baby step number seven all right so 20
years ago i started listening to you
driving around going to medical clinics
every single day oh my gosh and this is
um his income not mine i'm a
stay-at-home mom oh well it's your
income too because you're that's true
absolutely cause you're doing the real
work
ceo of the house that's it that's it
well congratulations you guys so house
and everything
the house and everything looking at
weird people
absolutely i love it i love it well done
so how much of the 407 was the house
all of it all of it so it's just pay off
the house in seven and a half years just
like that absolutely done done mic drop
the incredible yeah what is this house
worth
so you know we we bought dave so we
bought this at the bottom of the crash
right 2010 2011.
we paid
i think 509 for it now it's worth 1.3
million
it was a foreclosure it was a
foreclosure yeah
yeah i needed a ton of work so uh yeah
needless to say you guys are baby step
millionaires obviously yeah because you
got that plus whatever retirement's
going on so very well done
look at you guys yeah how fun see the
baby steps work look at that who knew go
figure right yeah go figure so you
started listening in the car 20 years
ago yep
and uh you start paying off other debts
i guess at that point yeah so you know
we we plowed through we plugged away
you know baby steps one two three four
five really quick then we got stuck in
quagmire so we moved four times to took
some
uh career advancements at work
and every time we bought a house
we had great intentions of doing a
15-year mortgage
and
every single time
30 years so we get talked into a 30-year
right your your payment will be lower
you can buy a bigger house
you know and then we'd be in the 30
years so uh we moved four times four
different homes 30-year mortgages and
then seven and a half years ago
you know we get to a point where we're
like
i am tired of sending mr mortgage but mr
cooper mortgage right
a big check every single month
work was really tough and then we had a
medical diagnosis that popped up with
our youngest and you know what that
night when i was writing the check to mr
cooper
we were like we are done
this is it we're not doing this anymore
so we said you know what
we're gonna refinance we stayed up late
that night working on the refinance to
15 years and then we put a you know cut
that in half right 30 to 15. then we put
a plan together
to cut it in half again and said you
know we're going to be done with this in
seven and a half years and put that plan
in place good for you
well done and meanwhile the house shoots
up in values and then yeah the whole
thing works together
how does it feel to not have a payment
in the world
oh it's it's awesome
it's really good it's sometimes hard to
go to work
that's amazing so seven and a half years
confessions of a debt-free guy
it's hard to go to work how did you guys
stay motivated for seven and a half
years i mean that is a long time right
that's a long journey um
you know it just we just kept the goal
in front of us we kept listening to the
ramsey show every day and listening to
debt-free screams you know we heard this
one guy call in
and he was a dry waller and he paid off
his house and his entire debt load it
was like 155 000 in like 18 months
and then at night he was going he was
delivering pizzas at night on the
weekend doing uber right wow we were
like wow we we need to let's get this
thing done let's just get to the end so
you know we set a goal we just kept kept
focused on the goal george wow so what
kind of sacrifice was there were you
working extra was there overtime side
jobs what were those things that really
catapulted you to finish this so you
know we we threw away all the little
shovels
went out and went out the home depot got
the biggest shovel we could find and put
it in the trunk and kept using that
shovel but yeah i uh i tried you know
you crushed it at your job tried to
crush it yep that worked absolutely and
then she she did a great job you know we
bought that house and a half years you
know it was about
nine ten years ago
we didn't really buy any furniture for
the house we wanted to get the house
paid off we didn't want to get derailed
with buy-in stuff decorating and just
all the now it's cool it's called
minimalism right exactly exactly
and it was so funny because when on our
way out here she's like you know
we still don't have those bar stools
that we that we passed on like 10 years
ago and i'm like
yeah i guess we'll have to get those bar
stools when we go home yeah yeah
probably time you can afford them now
yeah with next month's house payment
yeah exactly but you don't have any more
exactly yeah way to go you guys very
proud of you and you brought the kiddos
with you bring them up what are their
names and ages so his camden is 17 and
cardin is nine okay cool so what do
y'all tell people the key to getting out
of that is
so you got to go get a big shovel right
get a big shovel you got a question
every time you spend your hard earned
dollars question why am i spending this
and if you have to spend it can i get it
cheaper
and then you got to follow the seven
baby steps i i would say if you're
listening to the show right now
go buy dave's book it's ten dollars on
his website and it will change your life
but you've got to take action today
right now this second i wouldn't wait i
would write it down i'd i you know i
jump on amazon and buy the book right
now or go go to the website well thank
you brother we appreciate you selling
books for us good stuff
all right well done you guys we're very
proud of you you're heroes house and
everything house is worth 1.3
making 200 a year life is good at
richard and jennifer's home well done
well done well done all right all right
407 000 paid off in seven and a half
years making 125 the 200 richard
jennifer camden and carton count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three
two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it is done boys and girls
wow
that's powerful 20 years of following
the stuff and seven and a half he said
no more mortgages for me lean in on the
mortgage at the last seven and a half
and kick in baby step six you know and
knock it out yeah that's uh that's the
way you're supposed to do it and very
very well done and baby steps
millionaires there's another one
um the number of debt free screams that
we have these days especially if their
home is paid off as a part of it that
are simultaneously millionaires
announcing is pretty incredible yeah uh
it's like a thing
uh that's why we did the new book baby
steps millionaires how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth how you can
to comes out in january but um
these guys are they're the model of that
it's perfect i'm so proud of them what
neat people yeah it's a great story and
uh seeing that those kids up there who
will never know debt and seeing their
family sacrifice for this long they're
going you know what i'd like a paid for
house someday yeah yeah it's a plan it's
a plan i'm gonna aim at absolutely and
it is so doable uh you know the trick is
to start to believe it's possible
and that belief thing is a big part of
the equation yeah you can do the math
and that's one part of it because they
said hey we cut in half then we cut in
half again and then we said if we
actually do this stuff it will magically
be paid off so it's part math and then
part doing the behaviors that cause you
to win yeah following the system and not
deviating no ish no ish around here no
ramsay-ish not for richard and jennifer
lean in baby full on ish is a wish
game on get her done
get her done you can do it these guys
are heroes very cool this is the ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225
robert is in baltimore maryland hey
robert welcome to the ramsey show
what's up gentlemen how are y'all better
than i deserve sir how can we help
hey so uh on friday my wife and i are
closing on the sale of our house
with the money we're getting from that
plus and we're moving into uh downsizing
to a two bed two bath trailer that my
cousin is renting us uh with the sale of
that plus a difference in our living
expenses we're going to be debt-free in
about six months
and
in about a year or so we'll plan on
buying a bigger better house for
uh i have a young son and plan on having
more here in the future good for you so
my question is
between now and then should i get myself
smart on real estate so i don't have to
have a real estate agent or is it worth
biting the bullet and just paying for
that agent and trying to you know save
money wherever i can
very seldom does the buyer pay the agent
anyway
typically the seller pays the commission
yeah i because the housing market's so
hot and i don't know what it's going to
be like a year from now i was thinking
if i
uh if i wasn't having a buyer's agent
then it would be a kind of a check mark
in my column for you know for
negotiations
yeah it would be if all things were
equal but all things aren't equal this
is not amateur hour
and you don't want to buy your largest
asset with no professional assistance
never having done this before and try to
negotiate in one of the hottest
marketplaces in the last 100 years it's
exactly the wrong time to not have
someone in your corner so you definitely
need a buyer's agent
they will make you more than they cost
you
okay great because they can actually
cause the negotiation to occur and when
you're trying to do it one-on-one the
chances of that happening unless you're
unless you bought a i mean i bought 2000
pieces of real estate the last house i
bought six months ago i bought through a
real estate agent
and i've got a broker's license
but i'm not active in the market and i
don't need to be negotiating up in this
market messing with all these people it
man
and i guarantee you i made money on that
transaction
matter of fact i bought two properties
this year come to think of it uh two two
houses this year and both of them i used
a real estate agent on yeah now we
bought a huge piece of development land
my son-in-law does all our rip manages
all our real estate and he managed that
transaction he's a broker too but i mean
that was that was a little different
play that was that had zeros on it but
um but a lot of people do go well dave i
can save on the three percent the six
percent if i do it myself and i had some
family try that the for sale by owner
and it was a nightmare yeah here's the
thing here's what's interesting the
agent there are the the people selling
the house put it up for sale by owner to
try to save the commission and you know
when the people come to buy from a for
sale by owner what they're thinking is
well they don't have to pay a commission
so i should be able to get a better deal
well you can't both save the same
commission it's not mathematically
possible and so you're going to end up
splitting it down the middle and you're
going to end up screwing up something in
the transaction it's going to cost you a
lot more because of your lack of
knowledge of how the transaction goes
down
than the little bit of commission that's
commission's not your problem in this
market there's a lot of problems and
ain't one of them
hannah's with us in raleigh north
carolina hi hannah welcome to the ramsey
show
hi there how are you better than i
deserve how can george and i help
okay um so i am let's see
basically i've been um not in debt but
also not
broke um
i've been see i'm trying to get my
background here
so backstory i just came into
300 000 of liquid assets because my
father passed away i'm sorry
um
it's fine it's kind of a redemption
story sort of interesting but
he um
we hadn't found him for 17 years so
through this he resurfaced and um
we were all joking wouldn't it be funny
if he died a millionaire turned out he
did
basically and he left
this to us four kids we split it four
ways so um
basically i have gone to from just kind
of being the average
uh
average girl that's
not really planning for the future to
now i have this chunk
to
have this opportunity to do something
smart
so
how old are you um
i'm i'm kind of old
yeah
but yeah so i mean i went to college
late and then i've just been working
hard but how much do you make
so currently
uh
i haven't even done the math on that 20
bucks an hour it's not something to
frown at i don't think
um what did that come to 40 000 a year
maybe 45 44 or something like that yeah
so and that's um
you know i currently i have i'm down to
two thousand dollars of debt i've never
had much debt i've stayed out of it um i
did me i did get a college degree
because my grandma offered to buy me one
so i don't have any student loans um i
wouldn't have gone to school so what's
your question for us today
so my question is mainly well here's the
other side of the story
my husband and i both run our own
businesses and we've gotten to the point
where we both agreed that having our own
property to do it is going to be
ultimately
um the smartest way to do it so
um at your job what kind of a business
do you have oh currently i have well i
have my own personal business that i'm
starting and it's not it's not like
underway because i don't have a place to
do it so i've got it i've got a lot of
clearance
um it's it's a whole it's a pony
operation basically we've got i've got
this is
people think i'm crazy i've got three
ponies that i've managed to keep through
leaving my parents house going through
college everything i've supported them
the whole way
um and they do like pony rides and they
do
ultimately i want to be doing equine
therapy so i've been educating myself
for a while what does your husband do
he's a pro recording engineer he's got a
full pro studio
um that he bought for himself
and he's already got you know album one
more time then i'm gonna circle back
what's your question
my question is
um what the husband thinks is we should
just go ahead and spend this on a
property or a house because we've got it
and then we
um
basically he's talking about being
housepoor get a place and then have no
mortgage and would not be awesome and my
thing is yes but i have you know a lot
of
uh 83 000 is like iras and the rest is
stocks and my thought is well if you put
it into one hard asset then none of it's
working for you
and
advisors are telling me oh this is a
great time to get a mortgage because
it's at like three percent interest at
the most to get a mortgage
um so my question is do i go into a
mortgage or do i go ahead and just spend
this chunk on a house and continue being
who i am which is the girl who just got
you okay so
i i wouldn't do this unless you've got a
paid for house but it sounds like you
don't need this property right now
so i don't know you said you had some
single stocks going on as well i would
get a new financial advisor if they're
telling you to go into debt and they're
telling you to invest in single stocks
the reason they want you to go into debt
is they don't want you to use this money
they would rather make a commission on
this money when they invest it for you
they have a little bit of a conflict of
interest in their advice to say the
least
so there's a lot going on here all right
so let me just i'm just gonna be real
playing with you kiddo
pony lady meets
recording engineer
two
ideas both of which have a high
probability of losing your butt
losing money running these as full-time
businesses and so do not invest in the
property to do either one of these
business ideas rent the property to do
these business ideas on a commercial
basis
invest in and buy a home and pay cash
with it with this money
that way you can't get to the money and
screw it up
and then go live your life on your
income go create some income to build
your businesses with and to grow your
pony business and for him to grow his
recording business but all on a rental
basis
do not buy commercial recording studios
never i'm in nashville
you know you get the next country music
star's attention in nashville uh waiter
and so they're on every corner and
there's a [ __ ] there's a dadgum
recording studio in every trailer in a
50-mile radius around here it's
ridiculous don't put money in that
period
and don't put and don't and your
business your pony business is a hobby
it's not a business it's never been a
business it's been a hobby since college
so it's okay to try to grow these things
but do them on rental properties and own
your house paid for cash to protect you
from you
that's what i'm hearing that's a little
blunt but that's what i heard this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsey show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print
the tenth episode for season one dropped
today the fine print podcast be sure and
check it out this one's um all about
robin hood
and we're not talking about a guy with a
band of merry men we're talking about an
app here that uh has been quite
controversial and
has pretty much been ripped to shreds by
a whole bunch of people and is in real
serious trouble yeah and we actually
talked to kate rooney from cnbc uh tech
reporter and she really unpacked this
for us along with jerry walsh at finra
because they find them 70 million
dollars the biggest fine ever levied uh
against anyone and it was for good
reason and so we unpack what's going on
with robin hood and if you should be
putting your money there and what your
options are when it comes to diy
investing
merry band of thieves is that what uh
that sounds right it's been a while
robin has old school yeah
there you go check it out check it out
being sure and do that call us here
we'll talk to you today about your life
and your money alexandria is with us in
canada hi alexandria how are
you hi i'm good how are you better than
i deserve what's up
um so my question for you is around
housing i'm willing to move but having a
difficult time deciding what to do
i'm 28 years old i'm from vancouver
canada i recently graduated with my
degree so i made 40 an hour now
i've been living on my own for 10 years
but before now i've never made more than
35 000
i live in a very small dark basement
suite there's no natural lighting but
it's what i could afford while i was in
school
my rent was fifty percent of my income
before 25 now
but my housing situation is having a
negative impact on my mental health
um again it's just very dark and small
and it's really negatively impacting me
but i am not able to find anything else
that seems
like a smart choice financially
the cheapest basement suite i can find
right now is 1300 i currently change
980.
um
moving to a different town seems silly
because i make as much as you can make
with my degree
and so if i move somewhere else i'm
likely to make less money
i tried to get pre-approved for mortgage
but my finances weren't high enough i
haven't made enough money
and so i just don't really know what to
do i feel like i'm stuck between a rock
and a hard place i can't find a rental
that's feasible i can't buy where i'm
living right now is really
making my mental health suffer and yeah
i just don't know what to do
so why are you looking at basement
suites have you looked at just an
apartment well she lives in a basement
yeah but you said you looked at another
one
and there are 1300s yeah i mean
it's all the same
i would live anywhere okay
well
you make forty dollars an hour do you
have any debt
um so i have student loans taken out and
i have thirty one thousand but i also
have the full amount sitting in an
investment right now
um so like in a brokerage account
non-retirement
yeah yeah so i have 35 595 in my in my
uh investment right now and i owe 31
thousand six hundred eighty one dollars
in student loans so i have like four
thousand technically that's mine
if you actually you're going to cash out
and pay those student loans off today
i know that's what you would teach but
the investment's getting really low
but you're broke
i'm confused why did you call us for
help if you don't do what we teach
um because
i i'm really interested in your advice
about my housing situation specifically
well the housing situation gets tied
into your debt and how much money you
have and how much margin you have could
you afford this 1300 in rent if you
didn't have any debt
um no even if i paid the student loan
back i think i'd still be in the same
position because i'm just basing it off
my income only would you be willing to
get a roommate
i've had roommates before
until the last year i've lived on my own
for 10 years and i'm just really feeling
like at this point in my life i need to
prioritize living on my own to ensure
that i prioritize my wellness
i've lived with over like 40. well let
me help you being broke is going to mess
with your wellness too
yeah it is so something's got to give
here
you can't just make up your own rules
and call it wellness
um you know you can't you get you if you
want to move out of the basement i don't
really blame you for that uh but you're
probably going to have a roommate or
you're going to move to a different city
and you're going to investigate what you
can make in a different city where
there's a lower market with real estate
but probably a lower market on wages is
not necessarily wrong what's your degree
in
child and youth care counseling
so it's similar to social work yeah yeah
well it probably will not be
dramatically different if you move to a
real estate market that is way cheaper i
don't let's say 25 cheaper i doubt your
wages dropped 25
in that marketplace so i think you
investigate working in a different city
that's less expensive vancouver is one
of the more expensive cities in the
world
i mean you're talking like new york city
here
chicago miami these are these are you
know la san francisco vancouver it's on
the list toronto right
these are major metropolitan centers in
the world and very very expensive to
live in and child care and social work
area is probably very difficult to make
a go with that so you get to decide
which of these things you're not going
to do
but you can't do all of them just
because you want to
so i'm not going to live in the basement
i am going to have a roommate and i am
going to move
or i'm not going to live in the basement
and i'm not going to have a roommate and
i'm going to move even further out
you get to decide but you don't get to
make math up
because you ha and call it wellness
because being broke is also going to
affect your wellness your mental health
uh it's stressful it's unbelievably
anxiety ridden there's all kinds of
problems around it so
you know i don't blame you for want to
move out of the basement but you can't
put 73 boundaries on all this decision
and still end up with a smart decision
that's what your pinch is
and you called up wanting our advice on
stuff when you already don't take our
advice which is also illogical so i
don't know why our advice on real estate
works when it doesn't work on the other
stuff so pay your stupid student loan
off get a roommate and move to a real
community but you're probably not going
to do any of those yeah and i'm doing
the math here dave and if she's making
40 bucks an hour and she's working
full-time that's about 76 grand a year
so even after taxes she can afford a
1300 apartment if she got out of debt
and if she had her money back with her
but she's doing it her way with her own
plan
and uh i wish her the best
but it's not gonna work out and the
wellness part like you're mentioning the
best thing you can do for self-care is
get yourself debt free
well and and start putting reasonable
boundaries in your life that are doable
uh you know open loops are what bring
anxiety meaning on
decisions that are not made
decisions where you you leave things
hanging in your brain that you don't
have a loop on you haven't closed the
loop on it you haven't made the call is
is the ambivalence is much more
stressful than actual hard times
so pick your pain
you're going to have a roommate you're
going to move to a rural area you're
going to live in a basement
pick your pain
because one of them's coming darling
oh the third one is financial problems
pick your pain
one of those four is coming to you
you probably ought to decide that on
purpose
that's what i would do it's a lot less
stressful a lot better for your wellness
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
we all heard the saying it's better to
give than to receive and you know what
it's more fun too
and while you can have a great time
giving the latest gadgets or gizmos to
the folks on your christmas list you
also
want to give them something that will
have an impact something that will
change their lives for the better that's
why our team
is starting our famous week-long
black friday sale today
this week only get up to 73 off best
sellers that will make perfect gifts we
have gifts for him gifts for her gifts
for the kids and of course we're
including my life changing book the big
time seller the total money makeover
over 8 million copies now
and that means a lot of people have been
helped with this book if you're serious
about getting your money uh in order for
2022 or finding a gift that will give
someone you love hope tmmo total money
makeover is a must-have this year forget
the one-time use presence give a
lifetime of hope shop our biggest black
friday sale all this week at our online
store at
ramseysolutions.com our question of the
day comes from blinds.com they have a
100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free you have free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from jamie in florida my husband and i
have been saving for a down payment on
our first home we've almost reached your
recommended 20 amount and we'll start
house shopping soon we're so excited
about this next chapter in our marriage
but everyone we talked to says that now
is the worst time to buy a house should
we wait until prices start going down
before we buy
it's a good question jamie what makes
you think house prices are going to go
down in florida
i think the market will calm down
and i think it will quit shooting up as
fast as it's been
shooting up
but i don't think they're going to go
down
i got my real estate license in 1978.
the number of times i've seen real
estate prices go down
uh is like once
2008 for a little while and not always
and not in every market they got soft a
few places a few individual houses some
of the markets had bigger bubbles than
others that burst when the 2008 mess hit
but really
i i've seen price house prices shoot up
faster at times than others i've had
seen them sit still
or go up so little that it felt like
they really weren't going up
uh
but go down
nah
not florida
i don't think so
now california yeah they go up they go
down i have seen california go down
because it's so it's a wicked weird real
estate market
um but
not florida
i mean go back ask a real estate agent
to give you a 50-year
back to the 70s
a 50-year look on florida real estate
and see how many times it actually went
down
now
resort property in florida might have
gone down because you get the you know
you get the overbuild at destin and then
the crash at destin and then they over
build a destin and then crash it destin
so resort properties do have some
volatility but i'm talking about
traditional single-family homes that
you're talking about buying jamie i
don't think they're going to go down no
and i think the key here is if you're
financially ready it's going to be a
good purchase because over time it will
appreciate
like you're saying dave but the key here
is most people are not doing this
they're not saving 20 down they're not
doing the 15-year mortgage and they're
over buying their house poor and that's
the bigger issue i'm seeing here so if
you've got the money you've got 20 down
and you found that right house for you
guys go for it
don't wait when i was a little kid and
they're coming back you probably go to
one
we have these things called barber shops
oh yeah you go to a barber shop yeah
you're like a hockey you go these nights
they're cool it's a beautiful millennial
thing to do yeah it's a bougie barber
shop but hey blake thompson goes there
yeah
that settles it that's bougie for sure
um but i mean when i was a little kid it
was more like something like out of
mayberry rfd right you know like andy
and opie might have wandered in and it
was like but all the old man sit around
the barber shop with an opinion
and i'll never forget my dad were coming
out there one day and he said they said
i heard are two of the biggest liars on
the planet
they said and i heard and i always
thought about that they're a financial
planning firm too
they said and i heard everyone
but everyone we talk to everyone is
stupid
every they said and i heard are
they're just liars and they're dumb
everyone's broke you don't want
everyone's opinion on stuff so i'm with
george if you're ready to go buy a house
go buy a house now take your time
you don't have to get house fever you
don't have to overpay you don't have to
be rash you don't want to make an unwise
decision
go small go slow and steady there's no
huge rush
but the uh um
you know it
time to do it you know if you're ready
to do it step on it let's get her done
but uh but yeah everyone
they said and i heard they're bad folk
they're they're bad folk there you go
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five thanks
for joining us america we're glad you're
with us
all right up next is uh going to be matt
in knoxville hi matt welcome to the show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
about seven years ago my father passed
away and he left an inheritance uh to me
and my sister
uh of that he gave me
a lot more than what
he had given her my sisters have been
very responsible with money and
what she did empty is around 70 000 and
it's all gone and she has nothing to
show for it and that type of thing
however five years before my father died
my mother also died and she told me her
intention
was to split the money between me and my
sister 50 50.
uh she didn't tell my sister this and my
sister doesn't know about it i've been
holding on to the money with the
intention of being able to do that and
she doesn't ask for anything see it's
not something where she keeps coming and
asking for money and you know i'm
telling her no
but i don't want to i feel like on an
ethical level i'm just not doing the
right thing
uh recently about two months ago because
it's been seven years and i've been
sitting on this for a while
i use part of the money that i've been
saving for to get her a car just so i
can say i got something i didn't tell
her that you know there's some money
that's designated for because i want to
give her
stop stop stop stop stop okay i don't
understand
who was the money left to in the will
it would look to me that was my father's
intention but my mother had different
different ideas
so your mother changed your father's
will
my father
my mother told me the intentions back in
2009 when she passed away okay
intentions are not long
no no i'm not i know i'm asking about
the legal title to the money
it's your money right
yes but your mom asked you to give half
of it to your sister but she left it to
you
no well
she left it to my father who uh so she
passed and then your father
left the team yeah i changed my
intentions because my sister is not very
good with money so your father died
second
yes
and what did his will say
uh he's both said to
put it exactly how it was she got about
seventy thousand dollars in order to
make it 50 50 i'd have to give her
around another 120. and i don't want to
give that to her because i don't care
what you want that's not what i'm asking
what you want is irrelevant
you're breaking the freaking law you're
gonna get yourself in trouble that's not
your money if it was if the will states
that it was left to your sister and you
are the executor of the will and you've
not dispersed to her she's going to sue
your butt and
take you to the that's not what i'm
saying at all
okay not
this is after my mother died my father
died second he left the world the way
that it was all i'm saying what did the
will say
the will gave the money to me the
proportions that i described so it's all
yours
other than seventy thousand dollars a
year so it's not all to you so it's all
except 70. well the 70 was already gone
she already gave it to her now the 17
okay so this it was all left to you so
anything you do for your sister because
it was your mother's intention
not because of law but because it was
your mother's intention is called a gift
from you
and you're not obligated to do that at
all if it's bringing harm to her so
there's not an ethical quandary at all
your mother's intention is irrelevant
your father left a will and left the
money to you
and that's his will and it was his money
when she because she died first
and so your ethical is to manage the
money for you now if you want to be kind
to your sister there's nothing wrong
with that but you don't have an ethical
quandary mat that's what i was trying to
get to the bottom of
and you don't have a legal quandary i
misunderstood what you were saying
earlier
what a mess this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage beth is with us hi beth
how are you hello dave ramsey it's a
pleasure to be here good to have you
where do you live um iowa city iowa
awesome very cool welcome to nashville
thank you and how much debt has beth
paid off i paid off a hundred and three
thousand dollars good for you and how
long did that take about six and a half
years good for you and your range of
income during that time um between fifty
eight thousand and eighty four thousand
cool what kind of debt was the one
hundred and three it was my mortgage
yay look at the weird people you got
house is paid for
what's it worth uh it's worth around
three hundred thousand dollars
awesome
and it all belongs to beth completely
mine how's that feel it is unbelievable
it is just an amazing feeling don't have
a payment in the stinking world don't
have a care in the world anybody telling
you what to do and making 84 grand life
is good
well done thank you what do you do for a
living i'm a physical therapist oh
awesome okay good for you we got quite a
pt business going that's good yep good
for you awesomeness so what started you
on this ramsay journey six and a half
years ago well it goes back a little bit
further um in 2008 my uh husband wanted
me to
do the dave ramsey
financial peace class at our church and
i said no i don't want to do that that's
stupid
um so he got really smart and in the
summer as our kids were playing outside
he would turn on his truck and turn on
the dave ramsey show so all summer
evenings i spent hours outside with my
kids listening to you on the dave ramsey
show and by that fall
i was all in there so we took it in the
2008 right before the crash which i'm so
thankful for
he was a painting contractor it really
probably saved us quite a bit of
heartache at that time because we were
on that path and we knew how to budget
my life had a little bit of a hiccup he
and i separated in 2014
i had three kids
and i moved into a house into town
and we took the equity from the house i
took my equity from the house and put in
my current house and i had 90 000 left
to pay
and that house would be mine
so my goal was to do it in 10 years i
did it in six and a half
so i have a house completely paid off i
am completely debt free um
and life is good i love it well
congratulations that's amazing wow very
very well done you had a lot of life
transition happen i did then you went
we're doing this thing what was that
catalyst that really made you go you
know what i don't want to have a
mortgage for 15 or 30 years i'm doing it
way sooner i think i was you know when
the divorce happened i had some of your
financial planners who i had been
working with and he kind of said just
take two years off and just figure out
your new normal and i really appreciate
him for doing that because it did take
me a while to find my new normal and
then when i came out of that new normal
i just kind of each year met with him
and i we just set goals up and i just
finally said you know what i just really
want to be debt-free it just is going to
free me up it's going to allow me to do
things with my kids and my life that i
can't
you know and then when covet hit
it really showed me even more so single
income loss part of my income because of
covet i work in health care healthcare
so it really just fired me up i made the
goal of 2020 paying off 20 000 on my
loan ah of course in february my income
dropped
but through god's grace and budgeting
and my kids support i actually paid up
21 000 that year
and so i am just thankful for that i
struggled you know we pinched pennies i
i just really did it
and just kind of showed me i could do it
and at that point it was like you know
what i'm all in i kind of scraped and
found money and in may of this year i
just threw it all in and i said i was
done finished it yeah boom just like
that yes like that you're a hero girl
thank you
very well done thank you so uh who were
your biggest cheerleaders
um you know mike i did it for my kids as
well as for myself
early on i didn't really tell them about
it probably the last three years i
really brought them on board they're old
enough to kind of understand that
they all were required to get a's in
your personal finance class that they
said that they had to go through in high
school it didn't matter about grades
except for that class they all had to
have an a so they've seen me live it so
bringing them on and just sharing them
what my goal was i think kind of brought
us closer together and made it real real
for me so they were my biggest
supporters um and they came down with
you to do to cheer you on for the
debt-free screening i couldn't do it
without them i love it yeah it sounds
like they were your why too along with
being cheerleaders most definitely um
you know they say that um kids are think
it's you're not taught them they caught
it my kids have watched me do this they
know where my envelopes are they know
what my envelopes are for they know we
don't go beyond their envelopes they
know i budget every single month they
come up and say yep we can live for
another month i got the budget going so
they have seen me do it and that's
really what i wanted to impart to them
is just financial
wisdom and financial peace for them
because it makes all the world's
difference yeah and as a result you have
a paid for 300 000 house boom let's go
beth i like it well done very well done
all right
so
when people ask you
you're weird
you have a paid for house
i wish i could do that you're so
lucky how do you tell them that they can
do it if they want to get out of debt if
they want to be you when they grow up
how do you tell them to get out of debt
it's really the budget and i really
hated that b word when i first started
this journey but it is just freedom that
way once i set the budget i know where
the money's going and then it's the
discipline too
it does take discipline as a single
parent
making those decisions you know you're
in control of the money you're not
necessarily accountable then you want it
to take a lot of discipline
but i look long-term you know that's
what life's about is what do i want
long-term i want to be financially
secure i want to travel i want to make
sure my kids have that same foundation
so those are the kind of things that
motivated me to stay on this journey
very good incredible and the kids are
here they are they made the journey with
you yeah all right well let's get them
up here and let them do the scream with
you how old are they what are the names
and ages um i have nicole here she's 22
years old i have aaron he's 20 years old
and megan my youngest she's 18. all
right very cool what a great start very
very very well done good stuff well
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that's the next chapter in your
story because you're going to be a baby
steps millionaire before you know it you
are on your way kiddo well done and a
copy of the total money makeover to give
away and help somebody get paid forward
and get started on their journey and uh
very good way to go you guys i love it
proud of you good stuff beth thank you
all right it's beth in iowa city iowa
103 000 paid off house and everything
six and a half years making 58 to 84.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three
[Applause]
that's how it's done right there
and straight a's in personal finance
class there you go mom of the year
that's it well yeah that means they
won't be living in her basement
that's very important that's the secret
why
that's amazing i love it so well done
such a hero that is pretty incredible uh
some paid for houses today on the debt
free screening i think we're going to
see this trend yeah i think people one
of the things people learn from covet is
i don't want to be vulnerable
i don't want to be um
vulnerable to weird wacky stuff that's
out of my control out there and if i'm
the third pig in the brick house not the
first pig with the straw then uh i i
when the big bad wolf comes by and
whatever version of big bad wolf comes
by and there's one comes by about over
four or five years some kind or another
uh
he just huff some puffs and
you just smile at him and go you silly
old wolf you just wave as they pass by
the next house house is paid for dude
wrong house
and uh that this one's not gonna fall in
we're gonna be okay in here
and covid was the last one and then
there was 2008 and there was 9-1-1 and
then there was whatever i mean there's
always something right there's always
some pestilence upon the land
and i just need to be ready for the
locust baby because they're out there
they're real plague's coming it is it is
and it's not it's not it's not that
we're not positive we're just positive
that there's a plague coming
it's a different thing
uh you just got to be ready these are
the only principles that work in
wonderful times and good times and
they're the only principles that work in
down times
uh the only other ones work in one or
the other they work in all only down
times or they're working only up times
yeah and these common sense biblical
principles work all
the
time and beth
is living proof of that very very very
well done i love it i love it i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 128 2 you
will eat the fruit of your labor
blessings and prosperity will be yours
careers are a jungle gym not a ladder
shell sandberg said this is the ramsay
show george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host we're talking about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five mackenzie is in austin texas hi
mckenzie how are you
hi dave i'm doing great hi george as
well i'm very honored and nervous to
talk to you both so go easy on me
how can we help
so my husband and i are celebrating our
one year anniversary today
yes very fun thank you um but in this
last year we haven't fully been on the
same page as far as debt payoff um
different mentalities so we did what we
both understood with our money and put
it in a savings account
um because of that we have 130 000 in
savings and the unfortunate thing is our
student loan amount is our only debt and
combined it is almost 340 000
he is a chiropractor so the majority of
that is from him and what i know you
know about chiropractors is they only
really make good money whenever they
open their own office so that's what
we're looking to do
but to do that it's a good chunk of
money for all of the equipment including
x-rays outputting the office to be able
to handle the extra unit all those
things
and so
what um part of what we're concerned
about is should we take our own personal
money to open up office to prevent going
into
further debt with a business loan but
also how do we protect our liability and
assets as well as we are also in a
transition where i'm losing my job at
the end of the year and would be looking
for a career change so it's not
necessarily stable so we're just kind of
this weird place where we don't
necessarily know what to do with this
money now that he's a little bit more on
board with paying off debt but all these
transitions make him nervous
[Music]
so what's he make what do you make this
year as a chiropractor
um he makes 70 now i makes us 60 and we
both are a real estate team and we made
around 50 to 60 for the years that gives
us around 200 for the year
you did what with real estate what
oh we are a real estate team and so we
we're going to make around 60 000 doing
that personally
70 by himself
yes he made 70 as a chiropractor you all
made 60 doing real estate and you made
60. 60 in addition to that
yes
so
uh 190 thousand dollars did i do that
right
yes
okay and you guys are how old
um i am 28 he's 31. okay
all right and how long have you all been
listening to this show
i've been a long time listener um he's
very new we just finished fpu which has
really gotten him on board with that
payoff
okay
well i don't think right now is the time
just to start a business i'm going to be
honest i mean you guys have done well
with your savings but you've got a pile
of debt to clean up here and the good
news is you have a huge shovel and so if
i'm you guys this debt is going to be
gone in three years
i'm gonna throw so much money at this
thing clear and clear out the savings
other than your three to six months
emergency fund and you guys got to be on
the baby steps and get rid of this thing
before we go start our own practice okay
our system didn't change
all that has changed in the equation is
that
now he has seen our system
that you knew ahead of time and our
system is of course avoid debt
and pay cash for things as you go
and you knew that right
i know that yes yeah and so the chances
of me telling you to open a chiropractic
office and go in debt to do it
are zero
i would never do that
ever
under any what about using our own money
i wouldn't do it until you get the debt
paid off because you can be debt-free in
three years you just got married you've
been married a whole year
you have time and you've already put 130
000 away already
so i would use the same energy to just
finish up the debt and then save up the
money to open the chiropractic office
with cash
okay so from that i'm like pivoting from
there
with me losing my job and changing
career fields um
how do we approach our
savings account so it wouldn't want to
necessarily throw all of that to protect
ourselves with that well listen you make
60 and 70. you made 130 000 without you
having a job
right
right
okay i think you can probably get by
he said sarcastically
okay
well you can struggle through on 130
while you look for a job so set aside a
standard emergency fund you got 130 000
in savings
okay
okay so let's
you're calling to ask what we would do
if i woke up in your shoes where i want
you to be is to own a debt-free
chiropractic office and be making 200
000 a year on that and i want you to
have your career blossoming and me
making another 200 000 when you're 30.
how old are you now
28. okay well when you're 34 then okay
it's going to take you a couple years to
do all of this right
and that's where i want you to be but
between now and then what you're doing
will feel foolish to idiots in the world
and idiots in the chiropractic world in
particular
because they're all about how much debt
they can go in and there's this endless
pool of debt because they have this
endless desire to go and do something
that they're not yet ready to do and i
work with them all the time broke
chiropractors are everywhere
they're everywhere
and because they pay so much for a
degree that is not a medical degree and
they don't earn the income of a medical
doctor
and uh right wrong or indifferent that's
the realities economically and so
seventy thousand to a hundred thousand
is a chiropractor unless they own their
own office and then they get their
income up to two hundred doing doing the
stuff but otherwise you're making less
than that and you paid as much as you
would have paid to get an md to get the
chiropractic degree and so that's the
that's the world you all live in and so
in other words his contemporaries or
what his contemporaries or peer group
does is not a good indicator of wise
you follow me
yeah he definitely wouldn't redo it if
he could go backwards
but we're there now i'm not picking on
you for there i'm just my point is that
the group that is uh that you don't do
it the way the group he knows does it
that's a bad idea the way you do it is
you pay cash for the opening the office
after you knock out this debt so i would
put 30 000 aside as my emergency fund i
throw 100 at the 300 now i got 200 to go
let's be done with that in about two
more years year and a half or two two
and a half two to three years you're 100
debt free then you throw another 100
grand aside and open his office and you
will open it with different equipment
than if you did with borrowed money and
you can make a good living and you can
reinvest back into it as you go and grow
your equipment list and grow your office
and even grow other chiropractors
working for him and begin to build a
sizeable practice layer upon layer
cumulative effect of this and you're
going to be in really good shape but you
need to be the tortoise and not the hair
you cannot
borrow your way into prosperity in this
setting you're going to create yourself
a mess and you already knew that i'm
just saying out loud what you already
knew mackenzie so i'm giving you
permission to be you
you already knew all this and the thing
is this is a four-year journey and it
might not be exciting as hey in three
months we could go start our own
practice but the problem is you're still
going to be broke because now you're
going to go into debt for the practice
have 340 000 in student loans and no
income is going to feel like enough and
it changes how you manage the practice
and it changes the equipment you buy
because it's all done with borrowed
money and under stress
and it sets you up for failure it sets
you up for a longer term to become
uh
financially free as a result of all this
work so you can make a really good
living as a chiropractor but you've got
to do it smart and you got to do it a
different way than most of them do it
and sounds like you got a knack for real
estate between the two of you too
so um i can push on that button for sure
and then continue to work your other
career mackenzie
be patient
you've been married one
whole year
you've got time
you got time
you're going to be okay
do it smart and do it gradual and do it
slow please
george good show today fun times good
job james and kelly in the booth i'm
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
you